Eu já viajei muito pelo mundo é 30
países já meu amigo às vezes não é só
conhecer a língua da pessoa você tem que
conhecer os gestos você tem que conhecer
as pessoas entendeu PR poder entender eu
tô gravando os pastas dois agora e tem
um chinês que trabalha com a gente eu
percebi que chinês fala muito com a
cabeça quando eu tava na Irlanda tinha
aluno chinês também era a mesma coisa
falando quando eu fui na Itália eu
percebi que o italiano ele fala muito
com a mão eu sempre assim eu notei falar
italiano você fala nem português direito
V de lá italiano é sempre mexendo com as
mãos e quando eu fui na Índia eu percebi
que as pessoas falam muito com a cabeça
e com as mãos AB T que T eu prestei
atenção que eu falo muito com a cabeça
com as mão e com os ovos ó nada a ver is
FIPE tá ficando é doido He Man ficando é
doido é Paria viu